schwieriger besuch heikle themen die
bundeskanzlerin trifft den türkischen
präsidenten und stellt neue deutsche
hilfen in aussicht
angst vor dem virus china schottet
weitere regionen ab und baut ein neues
krankenhaus in rekordzeit und fehlerfrei
zum erfolg biathletin denise herrmann
holt den ersten weltcupsieg der saison
für das deutsche damen team
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und mit kristin otto
für den sportchef und guten abend in
allen auch vor mir zur zusammenfassung
dieses nachrichten freitag
und da beginnen wir in der türkei da
liegt soviel drängendes auf dem
verhandlungstisch heute in istanbul an
themen mangelt es nicht zwischen
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel und dem
türkischen präsidenten recep tayyip
erdogan
es sind sehr schwierige gespräche und am
ende gibt es durchaus bewegung vor allem
auf deutscher seite die bundeskanzlerin
stellt in aussicht geld aus deutschland
für syrische flüchtlinge und zwar in der
pufferzone in nordsyrien die aufgrund
der türkischen invasion dort entstanden
ist das war eine offensive die
deutschland eigentlich ablehnte außerdem
neue eu hilfen auch für syrische
flüchtlinge in der türkei und mehr
unterstützung für die türkische
küstenwache die im mittelmeer
patroulliert details über diesen tag in
istanbul von andreas künast die stimmung
ist besser als die lage
die deutsche kanzlerin bekommt türkische
geschenke einen spiegel einen helm und
das durch geschnittene band darf merkel
auch behalten
das war bei der eröffnung eines neuen
campus der türkisch deutschen
universität
das war der angenehme teil den
unangenehmen hat bereits gestern
außenminister davutoglu übernommen und
der eu einen bruch des flüchtlings
thiels vorgeworfen zu wenig geld zu
langsam ausgezahlt so konnte sich
erdogan heute sicher sein nicht mehr
selbst drohen zu müssen dass europa und
die europäischen länder den syrern noch
mehr und noch schnellere hilfe leisten
ist doch vor allem eine menschliche
verantwortung
sehr schick findet merkel erdogans
palais in istanbul und sehr wichtig was
der präsident für syrische flüchtlinge
tut sogar weitere hilfen steht merkel in
aussicht für die flüchtlingsbetreuung
für die küstenwache kritik verkneift
sich die kanzlerin aber sie setzt ein
diplomatisches zeichen fahrt zu einem
treffen mit menschenrechtlern anwältin
oppositionellen ohne kameras um die
gesprächsteilnehmer zu schützen
allein gegen 73 deutsche wird
strafrechtlich ermittelt darunter der 75
jährige autor ende anteile
merkel will erreichen dass man darf ihr
fall auch noch einmal darüber spricht
wie man hier vorankommen könnte merkel
und erdogan sie demonstrieren
gemeinsamkeit obwohl es in wahrheit mehr
unterschiede gibt die türkei hatte
wünsche die bundeskanzlerin ist denen so
wie es scheint entgegen gekommen auch
deutschland hat anliegen wie wir gerade
gesehen haben gerade wenn es um
menschenrechte geht jörg brase in
istanbul wie weit ist denn die
bundeskanzlerin damit gekommen heute ja
also es gab hier ein treffen mit der
zivilgesellschaft wo kanzlerin merkel
dann informiert wurde über den stand der
menschenrechte in der türkei das wurde
sehr lange sehr diskret behandelt diese
frage auch die namen der teilnehmer
wurden wurden nicht genannt lediglich
der türkische anwalt von dennis mitchell
darüber dass kretschmann auskunft
gegeben
man sagt dass man die kanzlerin darauf
hingewiesen habe dass ich an der
menschenrechtssituation in der türkei
eigentlich nicht viel verändert habe die
kanzlerin habe sich das angehört habe
versprochen mit dem türkischen
staatspräsidenten darüber zu reden sie
hat auch einige punkte angesprochen wir
haben den beitrag gehört was die
inhaftierten deutschen an geht aber wohl
auch der fall aus man kavala wurde
angesprochen der türkische unternehmer
und kultur märz in der viele projekte
mit der bundesrepublik gemeinsam
inszeniert hat initiiert hat der seit
über zwei jahren in untersuchungshaft
sitzt das ist ein wichtiger fall
offensichtlich für die bundesregierung
und bei allen fortschritten die man da
heute erreichen konnte bleibt dieser
fall aber auch die anderen
angesprochenen punkte weiter
streitthemen im deutsch türkischen
verhältnis sagt jörg brase unser mann in
istanbul herzlichen dank auch die eu
intern muss ihre flüchtlingspolitik neu
diskutieren auf dem tisch der
innenminister bei einem treffen in
kroatien liegt der plan die eu marine
mission im mittelmeer wieder zu starten
das ziel den waffenschmuggel nach libyen
beenden vor der libyschen küste werden
die eu schiffe aber auch auf flüchtlinge
treffen und damit steht die eu wieder
vor ihrem großen ungelösten streitpunkt
wie drängend der ist sollte den
innenministern heute noch mal klar
geworden sein anne gellinek sie sind
seit über einem jahr unterwegs über die
türkei griechenland die balkanroute bis
nach bosnien knapp 100 afghanen haben
sich in einer verlassenen metallfabrik
in der nähe von beach verkrochen wenige
kilometer entfernt von der grenze zur eu
x-mal haben sie versucht diese grenze zu
überwinden x-mal hat die kroatische
polizei sie erwischt verprügelt
zurückgeschoben
trotzdem harren sie aus nur um es bald
wieder zu versuchen
rund 150 kilometer weiter nördlich tagen
die eu innenminister in zagreb sie
wissen dass die flüchtlingszahlen
langsam wieder ansteigen
sie wissen auch dass europa keine
antwort darauf hat wie asylberechtigte
migranten verteilt werden können sollen
alle mitgliedsstaaten flüchtlinge
aufnehmen oder können sich einige mit
geld heraus kaufen
auch das kann man sich vorstellen aber
es kommt schon darauf an dass die große
mehrheit der staaten bereits in
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen und sich nicht
frei zu kaufen
auch bei der neuauflage der eu-mission
sofia ist europa sofort auf das dilemma
der flüchtlings verteilung wenn marine
schiffe im mittelmeer wieder das
waffenembargo gegen libyen überwachen
sollen treffen sie zwangsläufig auf
migranten
der österreichische innenminister will
sie zwar retten aber sofort nach libyen
abschieben
dort wo sie herkommen ist es am besten
man muss sich das genau anschauen aber
entscheiden dies wenn ich sie nach
europa bringe erfülle ich das
geschäftsmodell der schlepper das thema
vergiftet eine lösung nicht in sicht der
alte streit um die verteilung von
flüchtlingen in der
'es ist neu entbrannt und jetzt in ein
land im ausnahmezustand china regelt
millionenstädte ab sagt
großveranstaltungen abschließt kinos und
jahrmärkte die regierung geht mit
drastischen maßnahmen vor um das corona
virus in den griff zu bekommen
besonders in der provinz hubei neben der
metropole wo hahn wurde die
bewegungsfreiheit mittlerweile in zwölf
weiteren großen städten eingeschränkt
betroffen insgesamt über 30 millionen
menschen
die zahl der infizierten des dorf rund
900 gestiegen 26 menschen sind an dem
virus bislang gestorben ulf röller
es gibt den einen moment an dem die
ganze chinesische nation träumt die
neujahrsgala im staatsfernsehen feiert
auf allen bildschirmen die heldenhaften
ärzte und krankenschwestern die gegen
das virus kämpfen die eindämmung der
seuche eingebettet in einen bilderrausch
den genießt auch lucio an mit ihrer
freundin zusammen aber sie ist traurig
ihre familie ist in born sie selber in
peking und darf sie nicht besuchen wegen
der seuche wenn meine mutter in one vor
die tür geht schickt sie mir immer ein
foto von kopf und bis händler alles
bedeckt sie will nicht beruhigen
am stadtrand von one bauen sie
fieberhaft ein neues krankenhaus bis
montag soll es stehen 1000 bett nur für
infizierte es gibt gerüchte dass schon
jetzt viel mehr erkrankt sein
die behörden mit durchhalteparolen wenn
wir alle an einem strang ziehen können
wir das virus in johann eindämmen und
den export weiterer fälle verhindern
die ausfahrt straßen in wohin sind
abgesperrt in mehr als einem dutzend
städte ist der öffentliche verkehr
ausgesetzt
es fehlt an stücken und brillen das
medizinische personal ist erschöpft
bevor ich meinen dienst anfange
trinkwasser wird mit meiner schicht
kommt nicht
auch der platz des himmlischen friedens
in peking ist ziemlich menschenleer
nur die gala fire läuft am abend für
eine nation die das virus fürchtet und
nicht nur china rätselt wie gefährlich
ist dieser neue erreger und was kann man
dagegen tun
eine fakten box zum corona virus finden
sie bei uns im internet auf heute de und
in deutschland die frage steuern runter
und wenn ja für wen
da ist sich die große koalition nicht
einig befeuert wird die debatte ja auch
weil der finanzminister riesige
milliarden überschüsse hat die cdu denkt
jetzt an weniger steuern für unternehmen
koalitionspartner spd will kleine und
mittlere einkommen entlasten klaus
brodbeck berichtet der spitzensteuersatz
soll erst später greifen dann aber höher
sein
im gegenzug will die spd spitze die
masse der steuerzahler entlasten und
zwar deutlich wenn wir mal in der
größenordnung denken die sich dann auch
auf das jahr bezogen auf sagt man
drittel oder ein halbes monatsgehalt
bezieht was man dann wirklich mehr haben
soll
dann ist das eben auch ein teures
unterfangen aus staatlicher sicht und
das bedeutet sie brauchen eine
gegenfinanzierung 30 milliarden
vielleicht mehr
dafür sollen steuerschlupflöcher
gestopft topverdiener und reiche stärker
zur kasse gebeten werden
ja ich freue mich ausdrücklich darüber
wenn die neue spd führung von den linken
abschreibt und guckt was wir an
sinnvollen vorschlägen eingebracht haben
und die frage ist ja was machen denn die
mitglieder im kabinett der spd zu diesen
fragen selbst neue schulden für
investitionen schließt die spd spitze
nicht aus dazu schweigt der
finanzminister steuern neu ordnen will
aber auch stolz
das glaube ich ist etwas was man von der
spd auch zu recht so erwarten kann weil
es eine gerechte und solidarische
haltung ist
widerstand kommt von der union sie will
keine neuen schulden und er unternehmen
entlasten also über steuersenkungen
spreche ich gerne mit der spd aber nicht
auf kosten von schulden nicht auf kosten
von investitionen
wir brauchen zur sicherung der
arbeitsplätze eine
unternehmenssteuerreform also da gibt es
sehr viel gesprächsbedarf klingt nicht
nach schneller lösung beide seiten
sammeln munition nächstes hier
spätestens ist wahlkampf ein ziemlich
ungewöhnliches signal der ig metall vor
der anstehenden tarifrunde
da geht es um 4 millionen beschäftigte
in einer arbeitswelt die sich gerade
radikal verändert und genau deswegen
setzt die gewerkschaft diesmal nicht auf
eine konkrete gehaltsforderung ihr
heutiges angebot an die arbeitgeber
lieber über sichere jobs und
zukunftsperspektiven reden und so
gemeinsam den digitalen wandel schultern
konkret fordert die gewerkschaft von den
unternehmen etwa mehr altersteilzeit
weiterbildung und investitionen um den
lohn soll es auch aber dann erst in
zweiter linie gehen und diese nachricht
heute für die deutsche fluggesellschaft
condor und ihre kunden nach langer suche
gibt es einen käufer für das unternehmen
die polnische airline lot übernimmt den
deutschen ferienflieger condor hatte
seit der pleite des mutterkonzerns
thomascook probleme konnte nur weiter
fliegen weil der deutsche staat mit 380
millionen euro eingesprungen ist
die steuergelder wollen die polen jetzt
zurückzahlen und knapp 5000 condor
mitarbeiter können erst einmal aufatmen
stefan schlosser als das neue logo des
ferienfliegers vor kurzem vorgestellt
wurde war noch gar nicht klar wie es
weitergehen soll
diese ungewissheit ist vorbei es gab
mehrere interessenten das beste angebot
machte die polnische fluggesellschaft
lot sie wird neuer eigentümer von konto
für condor unsere partner unsere
mitarbeiter unsere kunden bedeutet
dieser schritt vor allen dingen zwei
dinge das eine ist natürlich eine
sicherheit aber das andere ist auch eine
perspektive und darüber freuen wir uns
sehr
die marke condor bleibt wie sie ist für
passagiere ändert sich vorerst nichts
alle gebuchten flüge finden wie bisher
statt condor wird weiter vom bisherigen
management geführt
die polnische lot ist konsequent auf
wachstumskurs zusammen soll jetzt einer
der führenden luftfahrtkonzern europas
mit mehr als 20 millionen passagieren
pro jahr entstehen
beide marken würden sich perfekt
ergänzen ich finde es eine wirklich
tolle firma eine eine traummarke für
alle ferien kunden
das ist wirklich wichtig für uns ich
muss sagen auch lot war nicht besonders
in diesen markt engagiert in den
vergangenen monaten konnte konto nur
dank eines überbrückungskredits vom bund
und dem land hessen den flugbetrieb
aufrecht erhalten
niemandem ist ein schatz
für konto und die beschäftigten ein ende
ohne schrecken jetzt soll wieder
investiert werden der neue eigentümer
verspricht neue flugzeuge und weitere
reiseziele noch eine interessante
personalie aus der wirtschaft sigmar
gabriel ehemalige spd-chef
außenwirtschafts umweltminister soll
aufsichtsrat der deutschen bank werden
er selbst sprach von einer großen ehre
mit rechtlichen problemen muss gabriel
nicht rechnen die wartezeit bei einem
wechsel frühere regierungsmitglieder in
die wirtschaft ist für gabriel
abgelaufen
die deutsche bank steckt mitten in einem
umbau weltweit fallen 18.000 stellen weg
aus rot am see im nordosten von baden
württemberg kommen heute mittag
verstörende eilmeldungen sechs tote und
mehrere verletzte
die ermittler sagen ein 26-jähriger mann
habe dort seinen vater seiner mutter und
mehrere weitere verwandte erschossen
der tatverdächtige wurde festgenommen
simon pfanzelt fasst zusammen um 12 uhr
48 meldet sich der tatverdächtige bei
der polizei sagt er habe mehrere
menschen erschossen
am tatort einer gaststätte in rot am see
finden die einsatzkräfte sechs leichen
einige von ihnen haben im gebäude
gewohnt alle opfer waren offenbar
verwandt mit dem mutmaßlichen schützen
nach aktuellem stand getötet vater
mutter und die weiteren
verwandtschaftlichen verhältnisse würden
derzeit noch geklärt
widerstandslos lässt sich der
verdächtige festnehmen
der 26 jährige deutsche sei vorher nicht
polizeilich in erscheinung getreten
heißt es heute soll er mit einer pistole
um sich geschossen haben
der täter besitzt legal eine waffe mit
waffenerlaubnis eine halbautomatische
kurzwaffe 9 millimeter sei die
sportschützen am abend wollen die
ermittler den mann verhören
über das motiv ist noch nichts bekannt
die polizei hat dazu aufgerufen auf
spekulationen zu verzichten
so jetzt können wir wirklich noch ein
schnitt in dieser sendung machen und
sodann zum sport rüberkommen mit
christian schöne erste saison erfolg für
die deutschen biathlon
denise herrmann aus oberwiesenthal
triumphiert in pokljuka slowenien im
einzelrennen über 15 kilometer
ihr erster sieg über diese lange distanz
nach einer beeindruckenden
schießleistungen es ist die pure freude
der denise herrmann über ihre
außergewöhnliche leistung noch nie ist
sie am schießstand viermal nacheinander
fehlerlos geblieben
nach dem letzten treffer das erste
siegerlächeln
da wussten sie schon dass sie auch dank
ihrer herausragenden laufstärke gewinnen
würde
im ziel dann deutlich der vorsprung 59,2
sekunden auf die schwedin hanna ölberg
platz 3 ferner hieß beeskow aus
frankreich ebenfalls überzeugend
franziska preuß auch sie traf alle
scheiben letztlich ein starker fünfter
platz mit gut zwei minuten rückstand
micaela chiffren usa hat die weltcup
abfahrt der frauen im bulgarischen
bansko gewonnen beste deutsche team als
achter enttäuschend viktoria rebensburg
auf platz 22 und auch nicht gerade
berauschend die deutschen herren in
kitzbühel
der sieger des letzten jahres josef
ferstl muss schon vor dem super die
anderen den vortritt lassen nicht nur am
lift ging es langsam voran
rang 36 über zwei sekunden hinter
norwegen des schahs jansrud zurück der
zeigt auf der streif eine fahrt eng am
limit mit 134 km/h richtung ziel rang
eins am ende
bester deutschland nicht thomas dreesen
der abfahrtssieger von lake louis mit
vielen leichten fehlern
17 uhr andreas sander ist es der in die
top ten kommt mit rang acht
heute hätte ich ein bisschen mehr drauf
gehabt konnte nicht ganz zeigen sich
viele andere auch aber natürlich
allgemein schneitler
ich habe es wird gewinnt also den super
g vor teamkollege kilger und in
österreich feiern morgen dann die
abfahrt in kitzbühel tennisprofi julia
görges hat die achtelfinal teilnahme bei
den australian open in melbourne
verpasste sie unterlag der amerikanerin
alison riske in drei sätzen
bei der handball-em werden jetzt die
finalteilnehmer ausgespielt zwischen
norwegen und kroatien sowie spanien und
slowenien live zu sehen in der zdf
mediathek höhepunkt des 19 spieltages
der fußball bundesliga das topspiel
zwischen dem fc bayern münchen und
schalke 04
der zweite empfängt morgen den fünften
punkt wäre super gewinn der wahnsinn
also dementsprechend fahren wir dahin
mit dem bewusstsein dass wir einfach gut
fußball spielen wollen jetzt doch noch
eine einstellung das klappt morgen abend
im aktuellen sportstudio ich hätte jetzt
hier noch das wetter wochenende wird für
die meisten trüb für einige sonnig
richtig was ändern beim wetter wird sich
erst in der nächsten woche sagt gleich
katja horneffer das heute journal kann
ich ihnen empfehlen mit marietta slomka
um 22 uhr 40 ein gespräch mit dem chef
des robert koch instituts zur
ausbreitung des corona virus aus china
bis morgen wenn sie mögen aber erstmal
machen sie sich bitte alle einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren heute
war es tatsächlich viel sonniger ist
noch gestern am späten vormittag zogen
dann diese wolkenfelder aus
norddeutschland weiter in richtung mitte
für viele blieb es aber bis zum abend
ein sehr sonniger tag und so stiegen die
temperaturen zum beispiel am alpenrand
bis 10 grad im dauer grau gibt es
dagegen frostig mit minus 2 grad an den
küsten lagen die temperaturen um sechs
grad und auch jetzt in der nacht bleibt
es bei solchen temperaturen von fünf
oder sechs grad sonst aber sinken die
temperaturen häufig in den frost von
minus 1 bis minus 5 grad am boden droht
also verbreitet mäßiger frost und dann
kann es auch wieder glatt sein besonders
wenn sich nebel bildet dann droht
nämlich reifglätte in norddeutschland
nicht da gibt's dichte wolken fällt ein
bisschen nie so regen stört aber nicht
weil es da ja mild ist und auch morgen
gibt es ein bisschen nieselregen noch
wohl am ehesten an der ostsee sonst ist
es in norddeutschland rüb in sachsen
scheint die sonne auch im sauerland
kommt die sonne zum vorschein und vor
allen dingen wieder in süddeutschland
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 2 und 9 grad und am sonntag
wird es ganz ähnlich in norddeutschland
steigen die chancen auf sonne für einige
wird es einen tick milder bei zwei bis
elf grad
schönen abend noch